- Thank you very much Priya and Ty,
for inviting me to this
very interesting workshop.
And I might not be the
most obvious contributor
to workshop on inference.
So, I'm a physicist by training,
but I've spent last
decade assessing science
and communicating science
as in translating physics
to physicists and to other scientists.
And this talk is not about causation,
so it's quite a change of gear
from what you heard earlier.
It's also a shorter talk.
So, I hope like we can
discuss a bit at the end.
So, I'll talk about the scientific method
and the scientific discourse.
And I'd like to start with the four, like,
maybe five paradigms of science
you might or might not have heard about.
They were introduced by a
computer scientist, Jim Gray,
who's also got a Turing award.
And in 2007 he gave a talk
where he said like, there are three
and now four paradigms of science.
And these are, have
appeared in historical order
like empirical.
That's how science first was,
a description of natural observations
and description of natural phenomena.
And in the next paradigm is theoretical,
where we starting using
models and generalizations.
The third paradigm is computational
with the rises of computers
where scientists have started
to simulate complex phenomena.
And what this is quite obvious,
but what Jim Gray said,
"The fourth paradigm of
science is data exploration,
which brings together theory,
experiment, and simulation
and is a different way
of doing different scientific method."
And he talked about it in, as I said,
he gave a talk in 2007
and months later he disappeared at sea.
So, he never lived to see, actually,
that he was quite right.
And we've seen quite a lot of development,
and actually we see a
fifth paradigm emerging,
and I'll talk about that.
But like despite Jim Gray
not being able to explore
his ideas further,
his collaborators put together
a book based on his ideas
and contributed essays that is called
"The Fourth Paradigm of Science"
and was publish in 2009
and is freely available on the internet.
So, what does this have to
do with inference at all?
Well, as we've gone through historically
through these different
paradigms of science,
which actually all coexist today,
also the way inference works has changed.
Like, there's no one-to-one correspondence
of paradigms of inference.
I'm not claiming that.
We can say that we started
with induction, deduction,
and we moved towards
statistical types of inference
in the age of computational
and data exploration.
And what I claim is that now
in the fifth paradigm of science
we see things like
simulation based inference.
I talk a bit more about that.
I'm no expert in
simulation based inference,
so don't grim me on that,
but we'll discuss it in a moment.
So, I'll go a bit now into each paradigm
and show you how the
scientific discourse look like
in each of these paradigms.
So, back to the basics
is the first paradigm
of direct observations
of natural phenomena.
We can see the scientific discourse,
and I hear I'm taking a bit narrow view
that the scientific discourse
is mainly scientific paper,
but it's true in more broadly.
So, here's an example.
Edmund Halley in 1714
had seen a solar eclipse,
describes it in a paper
for the royal society.
Here, in the second
paradigm start building
theoretical models to explain
empirical observations.
And we have equations that
are solved analytically.
And an example of that is
Maxwell's equations 1864.
This is the paper where he describes them.
So again, we don't see a lot of change
in the scientific discourse so far,
but it's clear like science,
scientific method itself is evolving.
In the third paradigm, we have computers,
and we can solve complex
mathematical models
by numerical simulations.
So, and this is a nice example,
a paper I particularly like.
This is the Metropolis Algorithm,
and it's interesting for several reasons.
So, it's arguably the earliest
computational physics paper
ever published.
And it describes what is
known as Metropolis Algorithm,
but actually Metropolis
himself didn't contribute
much to this paper.
More, he was the one who provided time
on the computer on MANIAC.
The people who actually
did the work were Arianna
and Marshall Rosenbluth helped
by Augusta and Edgar Teller.
And what tells us, let's again,
if you just look at the paper,
it's actually quite modern
despite being from 1953.
But, what we already notice here,
there are more contributors to this paper,
and they all have done different things.
And this will become even more so
in the fourth paradigm of science
where discovery is
enabled by the exploration
of massive data sets.
And the example I chose
here is the discovery
of the Higgs boson.
So, why is it interesting is
this was like a great
achievement not only technically
from an experimental point of view,
but also from the data
analysis point of view.
And already by 2012 had been used,
they had used lots of
machine learning to do
the data analysis.
And here like already
we're talking about 1000s
of authors involved in in this paper.
So Jim Gray thought
that this data exploration
was considerably distinct
from the previous computational
paradigm to deserve
its own, you know, separate naming.
How about the fifth?
Well this remains to be defined,
but there are lots of
ideas floating around.
So, for example, this is from 2019
maybe computers will decide objectively,
which experiments yield the
biggest gain in our knowledge,
and they would drive the
experimental investigations.
Other ideas say that maybe
computers will be robust simulators
to replace traditional
numerical simulation methods.
This is a stance taken
by Christopher Bishop
who's at Microsoft Research.
And actually say like
the fourth paradigm of
science was published
by Microsoft Research,
so they like this idea very much.
And then, we wrote a bit
more dramatic departure
from these ideas.
We wrote last year in an editorial
that maybe machines will
no longer be just tools,
but there'll be equal partners
in the scientific exploration,
and they will gain some
scientific understanding
that we share with human peers.
And that's a bit more radical,
but still like all
these ideas are kindred.
And now, I mentioned
simulation based inference,
and this is also expected to have
a profound impact on science.
And it's actually related to the idea
of robust stimulators,
because this is how
they get the likelihood
in simulation-based inference.
So, all these ideas have
something in common,
AI will play a very important role.
How? We don't know yet.
And how will the
scientific discourse change
in this fifth paradigm?
Again, we don't know.
But, has the scientific
discourse changed at all?
Well I say, "no,"
'cause we are still stuck in
the first three paradigms.
And again, I want to make it clear
that by scientific discourse
I take the narrower view
of scientific writing
as a way to convey ideas and observations
in a persuasive way to
your scientific peers.
Yeah, and this is what I understand here
by scientific discourse.
And why hasn't it changed at all?
So, you see like methodology has evolved.
We use different
methodologies at this stage,
but the discourse hasn't.
Is it the format
or is the audience?
And I will explore this too,
and I'll give reason why it is
and a reason why it shouldn't be so.
So, we're actually stuck in
print in terms of format.
And this is should not
be surprising actually,
because in the long history
of scientific publishing
online has been here
for a very short time.
So, the first journals
appear in 1665 and actually
the philosophical transactions
are still published today.
Like journals like "Nature"
and "Science" came much later.
And first online journals actually came
in the late '80s and
beginning of the '90s.
And the preprint started.
The archives started around the same time.
And so, these are like
new kids on the block
in the history of scientific publishing.
And "Nature" digitized
its full archive in 2008.
And as of 2007, I don't
know if they finished it,
but "Royal Society" was still digitizing
its full archive back to 1665.
So, we don't have
everything on online yet.
And purely online only
journals have only come
very, very recently.
But, even for online only journals,
they are still stuck in print,
even though they've never been printed.
Think of the PDF format that
any online journal still has.
Think of the table of contents
that signifies an issue.
And if you are in the trade
of publishing a journal like I am,
you'll encounter a lot very
frustrating restrictions
that have like historical
things like about
how you lay out things,
how you actually physically print
and physically bind an issue,
which of course have no sense in this age,
but they're still there.
And for like some 10 years now,
people have been talking about
the article of the future.
A lots of thought has been put into this,
and there've been experiments
but in the end, like we still have
the same format as before.
But, I think we do need to change,
because the scientific
narrative these days is
a very complex one.
And it is very hard to distill
in the traditional print-bound format.
Like today, a scientific
article is not like
in a Halley's example,
like I've seen an eclipse,
and I'll write down what I've seen.
Increasingly relies on lots of code
and lots of data, maybe
huge amounts of data
that have gone through rounds and rounds
of processing, of instruments
that are complicated in themselves.
And the parameters they run on,
they're very important to describe.
The methods and the protocols,
we need to know about that.
And of course, the main story also relies
on a large corpus of knowledge
that is found in the bibliography.
And we see that these
bibliographies go longer and longer
and longer as time goes.
So, everything has, all these
elements have to come together
and be distilled in a what is
essentially a print format.
Obviously, that's not possible.
How about the audiences?
Well, different disciplines
have very different cultures
with their own jargon
and their own custom.
And it's fair to say
without offending anyone
that some disciplines are
more modern than others.
And you see some
disciplines are interesting
in evolving and changing things,
also because they deal maybe
with more non-traditional products
like data or code, while others are not.
And what we've seen,
there's a lot of resistance
in accepting to change
the scientific discourse by
exploring new article formats
and experimenting with
different narratives.
This has to do with tradition
and also the fact that we tend to give
to associate rigor and authority
with traditionally established formats,
because if we try to present
the scientific discourse in a new form,
it will simply not be seen as
authoritative and trustworthy.
But, at the same time, who's reading this?
Who's benefiting from
the scientific discourse?
And I really, really
like this infographic.
Mind you, this is almost 10 years old.
So, what it shows is
the mountain of paper.
So, if you were to print the first page
of every single item that
is indexed in web of science
and stuck it up in 10 years ago,
you would have got a pile as
high as Mount Kilimanjaro.
I'm curious how high this
pile has gone up now,
but like my colleagues at "Nature,"
they promised that they
will redo this infographic,
so hopefully we'll see that next year.
But, of this huge, huge pile,
only the very, very, very
tiny top is what, okay,
if you consider citations as a proxy
of how much the paper was read,
maybe it's not a good proxy,
but how much this paper is known,
it still gives a very sad view
of like how much is actually read
of this huge, huge mountain of knowledge.
And it's true now
that the scientific literature
is increasingly specialized.
Like, even for people
from the same discipline,
it's really hard to understand
what is going on let alone like
if you're trying to read
from other disciplines.
So, we are getting narrower and narrower,
and we understand less and less,
and we have less and less time
of reading this whole
knowledge that is out there.
And this literature we are producing,
this scientific discourse
we're producing is
increasingly read by machines
rather than human beings.
So, what point am I trying to make?
Scientific method has evolved,
has become more complex,
and we are moving towards a new paradigm
where AI in whatever form it
will play an important role.
But, the scientific discourse
itself has not evolved
beyond the first three paradigms.
And I think that it's very important now
that as we move
towards the fifth paradigm
to try to find new ways,
new forms of scientific writing,
scientific discourse that
are more representative
of the scientific method,
the complex narratives
we're trying to convey
and actually the audiences.
'Cause, who we are we writing for?
And I think we need to adapt
the scientific discourse
to the needs of the
21st century scientists.
And I also think,
and I experienced this a lot,
trying to publish new art,
new forms of narratives,
I got a lot of pushback.
So, I want to say like
let's be open-minded.
The scientific discourse is not fixed,
like the scientific methods
is not fixed, it's evolving.
So should the scientific discourse.
Now, before I end, I want to
be my own devil's advocate
and preempt the question
that you might have,
and say, "Okay, like if nobody's reading,
only like machines are reading,
why should we care about the
scientific discourse at all?"
Yeah.
And actually, I think
the scientific discourse
will remain important
as long as we human beings
are interested in science,
because this is how we share the science,
we share the new ideas,
and we share the
understanding we have gained.
And a year ago we published
this very interesting perspective called
"On Scientific Understanding
with Artificial Intelligence."
It was a bit of a strange type of review.
So, the authors came up,
used like a definition
of scientific understanding
from the philosophy of science,
maybe not or people agree with that,
but they used this definition
as an umbrella term to collect
scattered literature about how
computers can help us achieve
understanding, scientific understanding.
And they use that to make a
survey of what has been done.
And then, they finished
like with the discussion
where they said like,
"We propose a test for
scientific understanding,
which is basically whether
a human teacher or a
computer teacher is better
at explaining to a student
a scientific concept.
And you see where this comes.
It's a sort of Turing test.
And fine, I mean you
know, you might agree,
you might disagree.
But, in the same issue we had
a very different perspective
from Matthew Schwartz who said like,
"Actually AI is evolving
on a much faster time scale
than human intelligence.
So, very quickly AI will understand things
that and will not be able
to explain them to us.
And that's fine, we should just
leave it to do the science,
and we'll go fishing."
Whether you're happy with that or not,
again, it's debatable,
but I think these different
perspectives highlight
what I was trying to say
in the beginning is that
no matter whether computers could
or should take over in
doing science in what form,
I think it's important that
they would explain that to us,
'cause that's what we do in
science in the beginning,
in the first place.
And how computers or AI will
develop a scientific discourse,
again, we don't know,
but I do hope that it's not the same
350 years old scientific article.
So yeah, that's what I had to say.
And thank you for your attention.
(audience applauds)
- Thanks so much Iulia.
This reminds me of the conversation
we were having just a couple of days ago
at a colloquium at FDS.
What is gonna count as a discovery
if we are going to have machine learning
sort of, you know, comb through our data,
get trained on the current
data and simulations?
Are we, I mean the nature
of what we counts today
as discovery is gonna
change fundamentally,
so it's very interesting, that,
but I mean do you have a suggestion
of new forms of communication?
Surely, you don't think TikTok videos are
the way we should go, right?
- No, definitely, definitely not.
But, I think this very
workshop is a nice example of,
you know, how we communicate differently
in different fields
and what we consider to
be a discovery, again.
Because, for me it was very
interesting the different ideas
and philosophy of science
and which one is correct.
I mean they're very beautiful arguments
for this and for that,
but like how do you
decide like in your field,
you know, ultimately it's
the experimental validation
of the observations we have.
So, for a lot of physics, right,
theory can be as beautiful as it is.
If it's not confirmed by
experiment, we don't care.
And in other fields, like
you mentioned medical,
like it doesn't matter what you find
if it's not going to
help me treat a patient.
And in engineering, it doesn't matter
if a device doesn't run
faster or consumes less.
So I think the first question to ask is
what do we want from science?
And in different branches
of science we want different things,
or we have different cost
functions, let's say.
And from that cost function,
we will define what the discovery is,
and from that, the type of narrative
that we want to use for
a scientific discourse.
- Thank you very much.
Any other questions?
Eduardo, Imad and then Sean.
- [Eduardo] Thank you.
I was hoping you can comment,
I'm not quite following
why you feel like the discourse
hasn't really changed.
So, I have my view is that publication
of science has changed profoundly,
and I will be very curious to see
a timeline along the paradigms
of how it's become from something
that professional societies were doing
to something that is today
multi-billion dollar corporate business.
So, part of that change has been,
and another major change
in discourse is that
it used to be the case that
you are describing science
as conveying new ideas and
observations in a persuasive
and rigorous way to his scientific peers.
Ideas being maybe the
introduction and the discussion
and the observations being the results.
A major change has been
that in some of these outlets
there are no methods anymore,
which seem to be, in my opinion,
I mean you really have to
dig deep and deep and deep.
I mean, it has changed.
It was easy to read the
methods 20 years ago
before the results.
Now, I cannot if I get the paper,
a copy of "Nature" in my hands.
So, I'm not following
that, it hasn't changed.
- So, there are two, two things.
So, first thing you mentioned is
the business model has changed.
I agree with that.
It's become from like
scientists like sending letters
to an editor for
scientific society to share
that knowledge with the peers
to, as you say, a business model
where people are publishing
and companies are enabled
in this publishing.
Yeah, I'm not arguing that.
It's the scale of it
has changed dramatically
and so does the economics of it.
But like, if you look at
the scientific paper itself
of how it looked 50
years ago, 100 years ago
and how it looks now, at the in its first
in this form, it's very much unchanged.
I can read the paper from 100 years ago
and I can understand it.
I can read the paper now,
it will have the same sections.
It will have the same
presentation of results.
It will have, yes maybe like a lot
of the complexity will be sent
into supplementary information
or in a method section.
- [Eduardo] But, it's the
defining feature of what we do.
That is science.
It's the methods.
Otherwise, it's a interesting
story in the Sunday newspaper.
- Well yes, of course,
but what I'm saying is the, you know,
- [Host] Structurally,
you are saying right?
- Structurally, the way structurally
and format wise, it has not changed.
It is the same way.
You're not sending a paper
that is like 1,000 pages long
that contains all the
descriptions of the entire,
if you look like a, you know,
at Chadwick's experiment,
you can find everything he
did in 20 pages or 50 pages.
And now, of course you can't do that,
because we are relying on more
and more information
that is hidden, right?
It's in either in
supplementary information.
It's sending to other references,
but the pure format of how you present,
you have the abstract.
You have the introduction of the problem.
You have like the main results,
and that structure has not changed at all.
It's the same that it was
like 50 and 100 years ago.
That's what I'm saying.
And I feel that is restrictive,
and because, and that
comes from the print format
that originally existed.
And I think that as you said,
everything should be there,
everything should be accessible
and should be able to dig
in deeper and deeper and
deeper within the same.
- [Host] Including wrong turns, right?
- Pardon?
- [Host] Including wrong turns
that were made in the experiment.
- That is another big issue,
'cause we are only
reporting what it works.
- Yeah.
- We are never reporting
what it doesn't work,
which is equally important.
We're also selectively reporting, right?
We are reporting like things that,
and the stories we tell are obviously not.
So, what I'm trying to say,
the stories we tell are very much shaped
by the collective experience of scientists
and the science is not in vacuum, right?
It's a very complex social
and economical human activity.
And what we are reporting
in this scientific discourse
is very much shaped
by the cultural, economical
and historical context, right?
So, when you write up a discovery,
you write it differently
depending, you know,
what you want to say.
Sometimes, you know, it's not objective
how you write a paper.
It's very much what story
you're trying to get across.
And that story depends
on the funding you got,
on the journal you publish in,
on what your peers think,
and so on and so on.
It's right?
And the way we do this,
like we have all different
ways of doing this
in different outlets,
in different fields and so on.
So, but overall, the structure
has remained the same.
Although the complexity is
much, much, much bigger,
the structure and the format
has remained the same.
- Imad.
- [Imad] Sorry, I don't have a microphone.
- Oh, move that.
- [Imad] Will it reach? Great.
Okay, couple of questions.
So, the first is in terms of like thinking
beyond like the PDF,
or thinking beyond that
sort of print-like format,
you know, are you looking
at some of the things
that are being marketed now?
I know like MIST tools
and like sort of integrated code,
interactive figures in a
sort of web-based framework.
These are things that people
are trying to come up with
that try to make that jump.
And I guess my question is A, you know,
there's one problem of longevity.
So, a PDF is a quite longevous thing.
You know, we think that
standard will be around a while,
and you can always print it out.
If you create a beautiful
web-based journal
that has all of these interactive features
and can access the data underneath
and can do all of this
cool stuff, you know,
what happens if that website shuts down
or something like that?
- [Host] Crashes, right? Yeah.
- [Imad] Yeah. And-
- [Host] Data gets lost.
- [Imad] Or yeah, or, even just
from an economic standpoint,
you know, that company shuts down.
The host of that server is no
longer available, et cetera.
And then also, portability.
You know, you can download a PDF,
and take it around with you
and read it on your phone
or on the train or wherever.
So, I'm just wondering, you know, how much
of the lack of perceived willingness
in the field to embrace something
that is better attuned to handling
the amount of data and complexity is due
to some of these just extremely
practical kind of things?
And what do we do to address that?
- No, you're absolutely right.
There's a lot of that involved.
Ultimately, the primary role
of the scientific journal
is to archive knowledge.
If that knowledge cannot be archived
and read 100, 200 years from now,
then it's not very useful.
And print for the good or
the bad, like it is readable.
And indeed, like the PDF,
we read Halley's paper,
we read Newton's papers today.
And you're absolutely right,
lot of digital products are ephemeral,
and that is a problem indeed.
And there are lots of
people who working on
how to archive science,
and how to keep this knowledge
and how to port basically these formats
to the next devices and the next devices.
And that itself is like
a really big problem
that librarians are looking into,
the publishers are looking into.
And indeed it is difficult to solve,
but it's very much related to how we,
more like, to how we do science
and how we preserve what we've,
all the data that we have,
all the code that we have,
and also relates a lot to
reproducibility, right, science.
And it is very difficult question.
It's not, and you're right,
maybe one of the reasons
in contributing factors
why the transition is very slow,
it's because it takes a while
to catch up with these things.
And there are lots, as you said,
there are lots of tools people
have developed, which are,
you know, again, very ephemeral,
because if the creators leave,
or like there's no more funding,
those tools are not available anymore.
And they're like big institutions,
like for example, CERN.
They play a big role in
the archival of data,
in establishing good practices.
And I think this can be
done, but you are right.
It's one of the reasons
why things have been slow.
(audience applauds)
- [Host] And let me thank Iulia
for a great provocative talk.